>> ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO.
FOX NEWS ALERT.
MORE LEGAL TROUBLE FOR JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
A GRAND JURY INDICTED HIM ON 16
FELONY CONDUCT FOR FILING A
FALSE POLICE REPORT AFTER POLICE
SAID HE ALLEGEDLY PAID TWO MEN
TO STAGE A FAKE ATTACK HE
CLAIMED WAS A HATE CRIME.
MATT FIN IS IN CHICAGO.
16 COUNTS WERE YOU EXPECTING
THIS?
>> WE ARE WORKING TO
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM THIS.
A CLERK TOLD ME THE GRAND JURY
RETURNED 16 ADDITIONAL CHARGES
AGAINST JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
THE COURT JUST CLOSED.
THERE ARE SEVERAL NEWS OUTLETS
IN CHICAGO RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
REPORTING A GRAND JURY JUST
RETURNED AN INDICTMENT WITH 16
ADDITIONAL CHARGES AGAINST
JUSSIE SMOLLETT FOR DISORDERLY
CONDUCT FOR FILING A FALSE
REPORT AND FOR ALL OF THE
FOLLOW-UP INTERVIEWS AND REPORTS
THAT JUSSIE SMOLLETT GAVE TO
OFFICERS.
HE WAS ORIGINALLY CHARGED WITH
JUST ONE FELONY ACCOUNT FOR
CLAIMING PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ATTACKED HIM.
THESE NEW CHARGES CARRY
PROBATION TO 4 YEARS IN PRISON.